why are so many young people suddenly so
angry well mostly it's economics steel
capitals Eric Weinstein recently got to
the core of it he said this quote
essentially a young breadwinner needs to
be able to buy a reasonably priced home
in a decent town with many opportunities
and provide for a second parent to stay
home raising young children you want our
parties to end this unraveling get them
to agree that when a nation cannot
provide sufficient opportunities for
young folks to couple become
stakeholders and tend to the raising of
healthy kids we have problems we
certainly do and we recently talked to
Brad Welk Wilcox the National Marriage
Project about this right thank you for
coming on as I watched the kind of
perennial popularity of socialism come
back you know people my age almost 50
think socialism really you have to ask
yourself what's the appeal what could
possibly be the appeal of socialism and
then I see numbers like these and I
think if we don't fix them we're gonna
get socialism yeah well Tucker I think a
lot of younger adults are concerned
about things like health care employment
debt and they see the government as sort
of a good place for them to go to
secretive security given the broader
economic context we're seeing today in
America so I want to zero in on marriage
because I know that you follow that you
study that closely so marriage is among
many other things an indicator of and a
cause of prosperity married people with
kids tend to be more economically stable
what can we do to reverse the trend
that's causing young people to delay or
avoid marriage entirely well you know I
think there are a couple of things that
we can do one thing we can do is get rid
of the marriage penalties that face a
lot of younger adults particular working
class and poor adults and things like
Medicaid the EITC food stamps I think we
can also do more to think about things
like doing more to subsidize
working-class wages and I also think we
have to sort of think about the cultural
context that we're living in and think
about ways that we can make marriage
both more appealing
in the pop culture and to think also
about ways that we can do more to spend
time in person and less time online as
well because it looks like online
culture is play actually a pretty big
role yeah in both the retreat for
marriage and the retreat from fertility
in the US I think all of us married
people and married people all of us have
an interest in this because you know
married people with kids aren't joining
antifa
and smashing store windows and calling
for 95 percent tax rates and burning
things down they're just not a country
with a lot of unmarried young people is
a volatile country so why don't our
policymakers take this seriously well
you know I think a lot of people think
of marriage as just a private issue and
that the government cannot and should
not do anything about you know marriage
and and and fertility related topics and
they don't kind of see how kind of what
happens in our families is a lot to do
with what's happening you know in our
communities and in a country more
generally exactly that's such an obvious
point why isn't everybody saying that
it's so why do we ignore this as a cause
of social volatility volatility that's
wrecking the country what does nobody
say that well you know I think it's
obviously you know things related to
divorce and single parenthood and
competition are very sensitive for a lot
of us I mean we all know people have
been in difficult situations and some of
these are reluctance to kind of engage
on these issues and yet the the science
is very clear so we've seen work by Raj
Chetty for instance of Harvard that
indicates one of the best predictors of
mobility for poor kids in communities
across the country is the share of two
parents in a community so of course
these these things really matter for the
health of the American Dream here in the
US thank you for saying that Bret Wilcox
I appreciate it